in slick in this hat I love thank you
thank you so much we'll cream well and
being honored tonight and today I should
say being honored today how does it feel
for you to be amongst these women I mean
I feel so honored because variety is
that trade magazine that everybody flips
through it's always on the table when
you walk into the lobby or any sort of
building in this town and someone on the
cover is always someone that's important
it's always someone that's changing the
business in some sort of way so for my
face to be one of the covers is truly
humbling and I couldn't be more grateful
and also the woman I'm standing
alongside of really remind you you know
that you're doing something right but I
just feel humbled by all of it truly I'm
really grateful by the way can we get
some like future projects put in the
works today I mean you and Tiffany
together yes please Wow I mean I'm here
for it come on Tiffany let's get these
bags man these Tesla's she just told us
she's got to make a little more money
the IRS to garment Oh what oh I know
it's okay call my accountant she'll help
you out I also just want to ask you
about the the organization that you work
with and what that means to you well The
Trevor Project in my opinion they do
God's work they're a hotline
specifically for LGBTQ youth who are
dealing with depression or are thinking
about ending their lives and these guys
work with very little money and they
they put in a lot of hours to be there
for those that feel like they're too
different for the world and I feel it's
a very important organization because
those kids are our future and I want to
make sure that they always got a number
to call when they're feeling down well
it's a wild time right now a lot you
know a lot of people figuring out our
future kayne at the White House
I love this guy right here what did you
think of that look I mean I think
family's incredible drug I think looking
for something to grab onto and I think
Trump is all that he can grab but he'll
realize that when he when Trump drowns
he'll be out there you know floating and
truth is to be real I think black people
gonna come in and grab them and take
hold of them as we are wanting to do
last question for you can you solve the
mystery
who is Teddy Perkins at the Emmys do you
know I do know I don't know if I can say
go maybe they want to be a secret
well here's you I do know who it was but
if y'all don't know I'm not gonna say
wasn't you I wish I wish I got that call
how to do that in a second
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]